all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 34 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
lots and lots of gaming news to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it and of
course we're gonna introduce those usual
suspects at the roundtable co-host is
missing we go get right into of course
the most technical gaming Lord the solo
game who links for the single player
selfish experience this week on a little
bit under the weather coughing up a
storm but you know midweek I sounded
like Barry White so I'm still a little
froggy but getting there we were
covering that now we have the excess
game the Lord was a man of his
confections demands nothing less than
the premium experience beloved Lord King
how we doing sir we're doing fantastic I
have a lot of stuff to get into this
week
we had um I don't want to say minor
because they're not minor you know
combat sports last night and yeah Chris
heard you bang junior he got in just
fight his knockout was spectacular of
all on his overmatched opponent again
the way that they imagined this kid I
don't think he's gonna have a stern test
until he actually fights a named fighter
so um but I don't know if the UFC had
anything please part of me last night I
was out the lord of combat with one
combat one night I was watching two hour
wasn't tested the the lack of
gallbladder to see what I could was
capable of at the bar shout-out to
Demetrius Johnson Mighty Mouse omma
preciate a champion in the history of
you see he did a move last night came
that was so crazy he did a king Tekken
move he did a jacking me
I grabbed you for the back throat a back
flip like that type they're gonna do the
back slam to you yeah he was about to do
that then immediate let's go and then
grabs dudes arm do some wild armbar
never seen it will consider in suplex
into an armbar it was yeah it was it was
crazy you know I've never in the history
of watching comments was never seen it
shout out to Mighty Mouse of the UFC
ring-a-ding-ding ended up go to check
that out cuz you know the king is the
king of the communist ports baby and I
don't discriminate I love it all um
sovereign I got a question
what sure was a nightfall experience
with these other people other than
myself as premium as the night I have to
say like we got in there and it was just
like it was surgical it was definitely
surgical I was with uh and look Noah
King a lot addict the first time to and
it was just like it was
it was in and out it wasn't enough oh
that's what's up yesterday one of the
life falls we actually failed that
towards the end so I'm about that but
that was the second time through go
ahead man those knife Falls no joke I
don't even want to know what the
prestige looks like but acceptance it is
today they run them clockwork excited to
get into that Ray too because I was just
I've been cheating I'm watching videos I
don't want to be a zoo of a murderess by
yourself I'm ready run it shout out to
braaap braap check this out bro I told
you I will delete one character to start
fresh but you get the grind on with you
you win I saw you you know get the
commitment to the game I'm down with you
brother the King will come and we got
channel 5 and all the affiliates that's
well that's what's up so of course it is
outlaw kognito here spreading that
gaming realness on the ILP telling you
not what you want to hear but what you
need is like looking already said like
for me last night yeah I definitely got
a little bit of UFC in it was kind of
fun and um yeah let's get right into
what the Lords have been playing so uh
solve
besides destiny have you been touching
anything yeah destiny is just been on a
switch like this past week we got to
2016 indie darlings that came out on the
switch to start a rally and the axiom
verge both of those games fantastic and
I think both of those very much at home
on the switch axiom verge this is the
second time I'm buying it I bought it on
PS Vita and FPS for cross-buy and I got
like halfway through the game there but
once the Vita once once Sony stopped
supporting the Vita I lost interest and
continuing to play on it huge library
and again the Indies are still being
supported on it Japan is supporting it
once the company proper stopped
supporting it I just lose the love for
it so some guys hold on a switch I
picked it up as a fantastic Metroidvania
style game Oh Carranza and then stardew
valley stardew valley is is like crack
it's one of those stardew valley i keep
hearing about it everywhere shout to all
my peoples over at Nintendo voice chat
you know I've seen them talking it up
shout out the people talking about
anything I guess all these gaming
systems and like a date simulator tell
me about this it's basically it the game
was created by one person
same with axiom verge so that in and of
itself is an achievement but it kind of
harkens back to games like earthbound
and Harvest Moon where is like it's
basically it's a farming simulator
you're basically in the town and you try
to build up your farm so you're planting
stuff at the same time it's like you're
it's it's a town so you're interacting
with everyone you're trying to get
married like you're trying to date stuff
like that it's kind of a farming / life
simulator and like the system very cool
because it you know you're breaking down
things in order to get other things so
it has elements of Minecraft like I said
all the Carver's moon and earthbound
it's it's an RPG but with all of these
other things intertwined and the fact
that it's one dude who made it it's kind
of alien yeah wow I didn't know that
wow that's no single act in I mean
that's sort that game and again it
separates right at home on a switch it
really is an axiom virgin same thing
okay okay so locate what have we been
playing that's now my destiny and um you
know cupcake that here and there but
Yoshi
shout out to require he asked me the
other day is Microsoft for widows games
that did they saw the indie games at e3
then when I was trying to tell them is
that they you know they're dropping them
out little by little like this one game
call and there's a very visually
stunning game it's called I think it's
called the broken planet or the broken
planet the broken planet all right so
that game is out now if you want to go
you know go to your store is free free
to play oh one thing you don't have to
micro transaction and you could buy
stuff to set up other stories and stuff
like that but the gameplay mechanics
sovereign can attest to is pretty decent
the graphically it looks fantastic on
your television oh yeah you know you
have the cover based system and a nice
deep combo system fighting system and
it's it feels like that what was that
was it wasn't ghosts in the show it was
a forgotten the name ghost of something
a game that never came out a Starcraft
game that never came yeah gave me a feel
okay
that's what some stuff about battle
chasers I know battle changes that I
mean we saw that it looks fantastic
I'm waiting for the switch because
that's where I know I'll play the game
oh you don't know if it's out on
Microsoft for PlayStation because
they're supposed to drop first
definitely first yeah okay but you know
what I'm what i what i don't like about
Microsoft and um you know listen that
they need something else like if I was
going to have these indie channels right
what I will do is I will take a survey
from people and have them check you know
I'm down with fighting games I'm down
with driving games whatever right those
games let's get a list outright
role-playing whatever and those indie
games that come out you get a flash on
your screen like a BART this game just
came out like highway Kings just came
out ten percent
because you're driving enthusiasts right
and that way you know these games came
out and you can go to the marketplace
straight to it click on this boom oh
yeah I don't use face like it's like a
segment it's not a clear-cut way to kind
of find and identify yeah those titles
no that's a good point
Live Arcade man I don't I don't
understand what the need to get rid of
Live Arcade that was perfect that was a
perfect segue right that type of game
shot off the log victim to Chinese and
an Xbox plays their cards right they
could really push indie games with the
ex and battle chasers is out yeah they
just gotta do a better job of like
letting you know giving people the
avenues on how to get there like to
showcase these games it feels like you
kind of have to drill down to all these
done you really gotta go out your way to
search with like those type of games the
ones are pushing at them them a Nintendo
I mean because right now you know Sony
you know with all their comments about
ah not you know not needing them anymore
so they're not putting them to the
forefront
that's microsomes chance to jump on it
because regardless to what you're not
gonna have triple-a releases all the
time you need some right if you looked
at their pedigree in the beginning their
pedigree nabina was showing all that
indie stuff where came to Indies just
add a piece to my topic destiny to all
day every day pretty much on xbox and
then um yeah messed around of course
with the 2kt a patch just came out
fixing framerate issues for the switch
so I'm very happy about that blazing
that shot a lot Eggman and shad he found
me caught me out there blazing he posted
by electrical gaming activity which
course which was got played I was
laughing at that but um yeah but getting
read
for all this October October Neary we
know we got that coming all these games
and we're gonna get into all of that so
um yeah man let's get these topics
rolling so I'm gonna set this thing off
um obviously the theme of this show is
the destiny to Civil War but before we
get into that let's just talk about the
the weekly update at Bungie so obviously
they started off they talked about on
faction rally shout out the dead orbit
winning the faction rally I heard it was
close they won by a margin of two
million new body was a close second in
future walk all surprising shots a lot
there was a chief I was out during that
time that faction right that allowed
them to form faction packages infinitely
what else could oh look at them now that
the movement was gonna spread and it
spread baby like rabies always my first
you know factually I mean the colors the
facts really talked about that and then
on the announce the first iron banner
it's gonna be October 10th 2 a.m.
Pacific it's gonna end 17th it's gonna
be control so classic classic iron
banner style they talked about what's
gonna be different they said it's gonna
be obviously the two teams of four
players instead of the six which were
you kind of expected we knew that
they've kind of went to this fall before
balance mode now they made some other
changes they said the fighting and
fighting abilities not your power levels
will decide the outcome so that is
different because um in the past iron
band has always been our
yeah you've always tried to get him in
with the highest light now that the
difference is in damage of negligible
sometimes five to ten percent depending
on the rank but it was always something
that was kind of used to so that's a big
difference the other difference is on
the bounties and ranks have been
replaced so before you people haven't
played on bandit it would be these like
solving would be these armed poundings
and like you have to basically try to
achieve them with different levels of
play and tell you what each one so now
those are going and I believe you just
play and you kind of get like the tokens
again like the Engram so that's a little
different so that was the first thing
they noticed they also talking about
seasons they showed the Iron Man gear
which looks sick I can't very Shogun
very samurai can't run on the gear gear
looks great there was a rumor that there
was no weapon Bungie has confirmed that
there will be a higher band weapons and
for the non PvP people there's arm they
talked about the Leviathan ray and they
talked about the prestige mode so
they're saying that recommended for that
is 300 to jump in or now 300 off the rip
they're talking about that's gonna be
the ultimate challenge as far as you
know what's concern now on I'm gonna get
right into it and there's a there's a
civil war going on right now yeah if you
hit reddit reddit is really salty right
now the hardcore I'm not feelin these
changes the first thing they want to
talk about as far as like iron banner
you know obviously with the power level
you know they're feeling now there's no
point
you know it's overly casual eyes
everyone gets a trophy kind of bit
that's how they feel you know as far as
the raid itself you know they're saying
that you know this it's fun but they
saying that the Luke cause in the past
of like when you do a raid you get let's
say you get a chest piece the chest
piece would kind of help you do
something on mechanic in the raid better
right it would give you assisted you
know maybe a 2 percent boost while
you're running around doing it or
exactly so whatever mechanic was in the
rate usually the reggae was kind of
tailored to the mechanic to help you or
give you some type of box right so none
of the gear kind of has there
and they're really infuriated about that
you know they're talking about um a lot
of it is also the grind so I'm gonna
bring this to the Lord's first let's
actually start almost our song first
O'Leary wants us he's that's the - this
is his new babe
he's jumping in he's what we we
considered the casual based on these
things that you've been hearing so far
about the heart chord being upset you
know what's your perspective and do you
even care because you're playing destiny
like I gotta give you your credit like I
didn't think so i Beyonder I didn't
think I was gonna keep you all you would
last as long as you've been last playing
destiny I've been seeing you consistent
when it was your like like 290 what are
you which is impressive time dedication
right for me I like the grind
I mean I'm that type of guy when it
comes and the funny thing is that my
issue with the first one was that I fell
off of it so fast there by the time
coming back and coming back to it was
daunting so I'm like you know what I'm
not even trying I mean no matter and you
guys are always telling me now you need
to come back me to come back I just
didn't cuz there's so much other stuff
out I said I know the time investment
I'd have to put into it right it's not
even worth it so yeah I made sure that
you know beyond from day one with this
and he too and I already knew the grind
stuff was gonna appeal to me because
that's just the way I play games like
I've said it before like when it comes
to Assassin's Creed like I'll clean out
the map in Assassin's Creed foreign
price anything I'll clean the map out
like that's just news game so this
appeals to me so grinding is it's fine
with me
uh my issue again I don't know how to I
can't compare it to how the grind was in
the first one but what I see in this one
is that because I know specifically
before like you could infuse this you
could infuse a weapon with any other
type of weapon it didn't have to be from
the same class and the same go like for
armor and stuff like that so they I
guess they streamlined it in that in
that respect I don't know I can't
I guess it would be easier to just be
able to infuse anything into anything
that way you could you know get your
power level up faster so I can see a
beef with that in terms of like getting
specific stuff for the raids and stuff
like that I got I haven't been in the
raid yet but to me it just seems like
the hardcore is mad at that a lot of the
little details that made its destiny
what it is like the little side stuff
and the little obtuse stuff that wasn't
explained like they're going out of
their way to explain more to bring in
more people but I think balance is a
balance that because from what I've
heard this rate mechanically is the
craziest raid that they put out like in
terms of like throwing just crazy like
Rube Goldberg like mechanical for the
sake of where is I so again I think
they're just trying to draw a balance
there where it's like they want to bring
in as many people as possible
anybody who fell off the first one they
want to make sure that they and them
ring them again so I think again this
this complaints to be had along the way
but again the game that we're playing
right now is probably not the game that
we're playing in six months to a year
it's just that's the evolution of this
type of a game so absolutely to me it'll
be it'll be addressed at some point in
time these issues that the hardcore have
in some way shape or form it may not be
how they want or how they like but it'll
be addressed but it's for you another
question because again your perspective
is unique here you know you're playing
this game and you you it seems like you
having a lot of fun so it seems like
those systems and things that's
currently in place you don't reward wise
oh they seem fulfilling to you they seem
to keep you coming back like what my
guess my major question to you to solve
is what's getting you to come back
because another reason why I'm surprised
for you specifically is you're a very
narrative driven type of lord like you
know so when I heard you kind of think
there was some aspects of the story you
were like yeah but you still enjoyed it
you know I'm saying but yeah
what's getting you to come back
specifically that's what I need to know
the tightness the tightness of the
gunplay and just that that that that
loop of seeing
numbers go up all the time you know like
any other game will talk about the loot
crate's and stuff and more things there
are certain systems within the game that
just keep you coming back and that crack
it's that crack what they do so that and
the fact that I'm not at the max level
yet I want to get the 305 now granted
once you get to certain thresholds like
once you hit that 260 for the first time
and their surname you'll be grinding for
a minute and you won't see any forward
progress until like you get the weekly
reset and then you get the new milestone
then you can get more powerful gear you
know and stuff like that so it there's
certain walls that you hit that if
you're not invested in the grind if
you're not invested in the loop you'll
fall for this tricks around that problem
exactly links in a harder mode you got a
running with people somebody who plays
it you know primarily solo I hit that
point and it's funny addict told me the
other day it's like aha you couldn't get
any higher without any friends huh I was
like just commit to the second character
right I don't think I'm gonna know maybe
maybe in future world but I don't think
I'll do that
I don't know I don't feel like I'm gonna
be doing that but that's what I've heard
that you commit to the second character
and that way you know you'll get
different stuff and again you help each
other because it's all coming from one
pool so no Dave lord King get the third
you're gonna stand here and listen lord
sovereign he definitely 100% knows how
to follow instructions and also how to
get it done we did that have no problem
without a knife or we actually finished
with minutes ahead it was me hemming
young Chris I believe that did that way
I don't know it was at him it was young
Chris I believe because young Chris is
my running mate even though he runs in a
different clan what I like
this year is that okay now all the stuff
we complained about before has been
addressed we complained about the
shotgun crap inside of PvP they made
shotguns a power tool so you know you
have you don't have the ammo this so
you're not running around shotgun and
sliding shotgunning I said it was him
that was running with you because we
just made a couple was it yeah it was it
was sorry you know many people and all
of us are elitist so we're
interchangeable number names trust me I
count you as the elite sir especially
with your cup head that I have not seen
anybody else perform this is a secured
sir yes so you know I like what they're
doing now as far as getting the casuals
into it because a lot of times like like
lost haven't said it felt insurmountable
but what they've done now is they have
turned little sneaky things to get you
into a good group community now instead
of proximity chat which I believe that
should be next that if you're in a game
chat and somebody's around you you can
shout out to him but being that we're
always in party chat I wouldn't even
know if they have process me a chat
because nobody ever lets me gain without
being in party chat I feel down um but
those are little bugs on Microsoft point
um but like the clan thing is this is
this time it's very important to be in a
quiet like your clan actually means
something other than having a name at
the bottom of that clan in Graham stuff
is really cool yes you know how that
helps people out because one time um
without me even doing the raid that week
how I did it but I didn't do it that day
or whatever I got a rocket launcher
because somebody in my clan have
finished it right and I guess they got
the red rocket launcher so that trickles
down onto the team I guess there's a
chance that you get the
rocket launcher 10 it drops at a level
10 and you a few stuff to make it
stronger and various weapons have been
shipped to me from trials from from well
I am banned I guess when it comes out we
will it would be the same thing and from
the Ray um so and it goes to the
appropriate light level on certain
things like certain things in the drop
at a higher light level so it gives
incentive to say Oh somebody said we did
not get this from and then they talk to
somebody and they Klan and I talk to
somebody in a party and they say oh
where did we get this from oh we got
this from rape oh all the gear looks
like this and it gives some the sense of
the going rate it gives them an
incentive to do this nightfall it gives
them a sense of should you do trials so
I got trials weapons I've never stepped
into trials but I'm coming into trials
this weekend um just to get it done
because I want to do it um but I love
how if you're doing a public event
everybody's jumping in and then you get
friend invites from public events that
your event public events to a great
place I personally enjoy doing them I'm
not there was nothing worse than that
like but this to me I agree with you
like it's really fun and then like
they're really raining loop down you can
even get if you prop the heroic you can
really you know get get that going
I got exotic yesterday from a public
event like if you get the perfect storm
going into a public event um like you
make it heroic you beat the mini-boss
that pops out on the side the the level
of you achieving an exotic is higher the
times that you beat the public events
sometimes you could be the public event
in seconds if you know the mechanics to
get it to a row it and then finish it
off it's it's beautiful how they've
taken our criticisms and it turned it
into a positive they even have a loo
cave that they don't care about it's
there and they want you to find it they
want you to explore it
it's not dropping exotic
brother it's not dropping you know that
stuff but you can sit they try to form
it and get some stuff from it you know
okay like I'm assuming you're three what
are you three or five already oh okay
all of my characters are three or four
three or five of them though for the
most part you've maxed out right you got
most of your gear you got most of stuff
you want for the most part Wraiths
completed yeah you bang out your nine
falls now I'm gonna play devil's
advocate for the people who are on the
subreddit so people who are really going
in right now this is the hardcore what
they're saying is like they're in your
position walking right they've got the
305 they've done their raid you know
they're not in the sovereign zone right
where sovereign is like a normal person
if you play at a normal rate would
probably be at where sovereigns that
right right it doesn't but we're desk
defeat this thing up we play damn near
24 hours putting them hours head so the
hardcore was done maybe a week ago right
yeah I was really done like a week two
weeks ago maybe as far as one character
max right brain all that stuff see but
this scene is in their mind now what is
there else to do because they've already
got that there's really not a lot of
differences and then their main beef is
that they don't like that like a
sovereign hasn't jumped in the raid but
he goes to Hawthorne he may get that
raid shotgun from a big grid like
basically what they're saying is like
they don't have any differential
especially to say that this special and
I am ban would say hey you you got to be
nice to get into this you know category
and earn and their beef is that now that
the light levels are gone from trials
the light levels are gone from what you
call it from iron banner that they can't
there's nothing to distinguish the
hardcore from the casual nat the casual
like I saw is just right there on a
level so so what do you say to that like
one last thing one last one that I'll
remember like when taken King came out
and in the arm sleeper stimulant quest
quest led to all is craziness right the
Lord the launch of a curious right and I
you're right there is a question what
the hardcore is saying there screaming
line is really not enough of that
they've got everything done in their
cars nothing else with them we do I see
I say to these little crybabies a little
uh-huh I need I need I can't stand these
kids like really what do you want bro
like you want them to give you all the
deals see that chicken is purchasing you
can max out and you can say I can't wait
for destiny three men shut the hell up
man you know what you do you don't live
right now team I've been so hard on
trying to coach my team up then when
we're doing things let's say we're doing
an iPhone as in anomalies right you have
one guy that's in the back that hunts
for the anomalies that's the lower light
level dudes so usually the higher light
level dudes keep pushing forward and
they clear things out the lower light
level dude stays behind hitting all the
anomalies bang bang bang bang bang as
you go forward you get to the room you
get to the boss pulls them forward the
end of the boss right that is coaching
your guys up because it puts the onus on
the too powerful or teammates to clear
it out for the guy in the back so he can
look unbothered at where the anomalies
are and shout out to my clue going to
check every day get your level up so
high just a junior
you know people are doing it and they
want to be completionists like I get it
first did you do it with somebody who's
never done it before
this recipe is about your right but
counter-argument that I have to agree
with them on that let just at one point
you said was that um like obviously they
got the sharper system they got the guy
to games whatever people are saying it
takes like a wait like an up to an hour
to get that going and that there's
really no specific reward incentive for
the person to sharpen a person like it's
just like yeah you did it I don't know I
think I don't know what specifically
some exotic Engram yeah like they need
to give them something some gold money
so they can buy stuff from the chick of
the tower I got a I don't know why in
command hit me up that he can get
through this stuff because you know I
see him waving his hand in sky but you
never had somebody up to take these
things you know you want to get through
something income and call a king right
is it a chase maybe if these dudes more
concerned with getting their credits go
up that they like level I'm done I'm
gonna be really is tough for me because
you know we represent the hardcore - you
know you're right you're right out
you're absolutely right was very super
casually now that I've become the
hardcore no only thing I would say like
see the argument that they're going is
they like you know we're the ones that
had destiny on our back right they're
like we're the ones when they
laughed at us for playing destiny 1 you
know I'm saying like we kept it popping
and I understand that and I respect that
and I'm saying
shout out could be money yet he doesn't
need to give it a center for gotten
games and the whole thing is that you
know there has to be a balance right see
the way I look at it is I got my male or
a sovereign sway your Z I got people I
got anchorman V who is gonna put me in a
time capsule all the crap a play destiny
like I got and it's like and shout out
to be money because I know we talked
about this on Brad before destiny is the
only game or if you look at it that
cross-platform people are still talking
to each other like y'all where you ask
what you can you know it's one of those
few games with it really the console war
doesn't really affect it like people are
just enjoying themselves and having fun
y'all whatever was going on so in that
respect I love what destiny is doing if
you want to call it being casualized
great call it being casual eyes you know
Sam so I like that but in the other
respect I do see one thing couple of
things that they're saying that I do the
things I seen people watching I only got
ten legs let's go
Thanks so it's like I do miss those
little sleepless stimulant quest like
honest you know what I miss I miss like
remember when used to like I feel like
strikes like there were some systems in
destiny one there for whatever reason I
don't know why they took I remember
always the plate of strikes little King
and used to have like the strike scoring
system and they had their arm you get
that you killed with different weapons
you get the rainbow and then you all
yeah like remember like at the end of
the joint you do Omni goal right you
have the chance to get that grasp on my
lock
you know I'm saying like that specific
gear that was there drop that was yeah I
gave the hardcore incentive I y'all
let's run strike show because we can get
to get this yeah yeah yeah like that
does one say so I know in my heart I
know Bungie is going to do that
eventually like they I feel they are
going
the biggest point of contention right
now just so y'all know why it's so crazy
is because DS DS the community
management budget came out with um a
comment right and a because the hardcore
experienced we like they were going in
and in well the experience I'm a
paraphrase would be said the experience
for him is about playing with his
friends and you know he kind of like
paraphrases to that in the hilt deej
this is not friends to me
this is not like give us but we probably
like they you know the best part about
that their customers say whatever you
say you are customer so you have the
right to yell at the top of your lungs
and maybe they hear you because that's
your I'm not gonna lie
Bungie is probably one of the best
companies at listening to us so if you
scream loud enough that special loop
that you want pers strength will fall I
think no a cup runneth over
I think they've tried new mechanics and
they want to see how this works if this
is broken
even our weekly updates that we get
right before that we you know everybody
notice it when they go in they gotta
update um has been shorter the times
have becoming shorter and shorter to get
back into gaming so they listen to our
complaints and they are active in fixing
our problems and trying to iron out
things if it doesn't work for the
destiny hole I don't think it'll be
there but when it does it'll work I
agree shut up guys want to say something
yes like I said like I think the game
that we're playing is be playing six
months is different than what we play
now and a lot of that stuff will be
addressed it just you know it takes time
they had they started fresh and they had
a base that they knew people liked so
they tried to stick to that as much as
possible they tried to change what
people didn't like as much as possible
but it's an evolution
like you know it's just gonna be some
people and not you're not gonna keep
everybody happy all the time you know
razor so I'm sure there'll be something
in the future that we won't be
necessarily happy about it absolutely
it's not the kind it look how about some
Chinese busy saying if they want to get
the new foundation set before they start
throwing that in and I'll agree with
that I definitely think there and the
new foundation is great enough because
again I just love all these new creeper
plan destiny I really do it really it
warms my heart
you know then to see people who you know
don't play destiny playing it consistent
and having that passion for it the only
issue I personally have is that when
they have systems that were already in
place that work
aka private matches why weren't they at
launch they were already didn't you know
I'm saying aka strike specific blue
that's the only thing that frustrates me
because it's like okay you guys had like
towards the end of the Destiny one cycle
day was on it write that off off off the
rip off the foundation that's the only
thing I gave now as far as all that
grinding people mad like shadow naked
man he made a good point he was like you
know so you guys want the old game that
you complained and retched about the
grind you know I'm saying back now in
destiny too like you can't have it wait
so I respect what that he's saying that
cuz this is for guitars and purposes the
better game now just a matter of making
a little refinements doing what you got
to do that's pretty much what I got on
that but uh I gotta leave these alone
man he just good peace my peoples I know
these listen off on th Broder 1% was not
playing it was a half of it because like
I said they wanted more information but
they also say they're gonna do on real
quick shot of the Bungie that they
actually gonna do it I have a twitch
event coming up I believe October 20th
and they're gonna talk about those
seasons in destiny too and how things
are gonna change from season to season
so as you see like you look at your clan
and gram right
you'll see like each level when you get
to level 5 you get this you get that now
apparently that's going to reset
different things and more things to
expect and what so it's gonna change
from season to season so that actually
is pretty exciting to me
they got it's gonna be I believe at the
UH twitchcon all Friday October 20th
make sure you guys tune in at the kool
Kat theater I love the baby cuckoo you
guys good to go alright no doubt we're
good on the crybabies all right one
percent just chill just chill give a
little time one percent that's all we
saw feel young he called his legs with
his title for you the 1% like milk crate
going on so what I want to talk about
today is the apparent obsession that the
gaming gaming has right now with loot
crate's it's kind of getting to a point
of ridiculousness and I didn't some
people have seen it coming for a long
time and I honestly haven't really been
paying attention to it but it's kind of
crazy um so we I know we spoke a few
months back about you know the
introduction of loot crate's into shadow
4 and what that might mean for how the
game is developed and how how they try
to implement that in the game and how
that would affect how the game plays and
and the same thing for 407 when we spoke
about that a while back so now my
question to Lourdes is now that the
shadow of war reviews are out in the
wild and people have kind of chance to
touch it and play through the game and
see the system to play and the same for
force a 747 is out already shadow war
coming out Tuesday anybody what do you
guys think of the implementation of
these loot crate's are they kind of
predatory are they are divergent Hatter
everything much I just got a question
because
I've heard about it like I'm act like I
know about the forces stuff we gotta
educate me on the shadow of war stuff
like I still don't understand
specifically how this is implemented in
shadow of boy why are people going crazy
about that okay you don't write that
down for me okay so I'll break it I'll
break it down came back hit and so um so
the that's all shadow war so shadow war
basically they introduced these loot
crate's that you can purchase you can
actually find in game or you could
purchase them through this kind of
storefront this new storefront that they
implement it now the issue with this is
that like the issue that people a lot of
people have with loot crate systems and
a lot of games as it being implemented
is that they're not limiting these drops
and these loot crate's to just cosmetic
stuff they they given you XP boosts they
given you here the armor weapons
um anything the case of shadow war they
giving you orc followers so and that's
the whole point of the game is to bring
art so the thing about it the thing
about it and in shadow of war is you can
play the entire game without having to
touch any of this so in that respect it
isn't super egregious and that it forces
you during the course of the game to
play it now with people having played
the game and finish the game the beef
that people have is that the end game
the true end game of shadow of war the
what you which the real ending of the
game is locked behind a mode that is so
grindy in it's in it's in it's kind of
execution that it it it almost pushes
you towards wanting to buy these things
to get get through it fast so basically
in the way moving down is that once you
beat the game and it's not a spoiler
because they showed you what the game is
about you're trying to conquer like
these big fortresses right so the
assumption is that in the game you've
conquered all of Mordor you've conquered
it and then you've taken it over so now
the endgame beyond that and this is
after the game is
quote-unquote ended now you have to
defend these fortresses against saurons
army coming back trying to take them
back in order to do this you need to
place stronger and stronger
orcs helm of these fortresses to keep
them from being taken over now okay you
can do this by continuing to grind
in-game and using the Nemesis system to
try to get more and more powerful orcs
on your side and then placing them at
ease at these fortresses to defend them
now if you're not someone who's gonna
grind through the game to do that if
you're not that person like in the first
shadow of war a lot of people had
complaints about the endgame because it
just turned into you running around
trying to capture every single captain
and have the entire army of Mordor on
your side and that that's basically what
the end game was and if you weren't into
that and beyond the ending of the game
which wasn't the greatest you had
nothing to do in the game um so they
sort of forcing you to go back into the
game and kind of be engaged in this this
this constant right trying to get plenty
more but like almost exactly in Iraq and
crow this yeah engaging world that keeps
going time fo from what I'm reading the
orcs have to be really powerful to hold
these strongholds alright so let me ask
you this question was off okay let's
just say I bought a hot new box like
what is the loot crate what is it giving
me like if I fight a little commit to
this thing what is it I just get a
random role on an ark an orc like what
what's happening it's giving you I'm
assuming that if you purchase it at
endgame or you're gonna get orcs that
should be powerful enough for you to
place at these strongholds and hold your
for team I'm assuming that I'm assuming
it scales but I have no idea and also
you'll be getting weapons and other
drops like that so the thing about it is
the greatest thing about it is that it's
telling you that unless you engage in
this mode after the credits have rolled
offensively you're not going to end of
the game mm no no no no and anger the
fact that you don't have to engage with
it it's still a positive but the fact
that they made it so that
it's difficult for anybody without the
time investment to go in and do all the
stuff to be able to come back and and do
all of this stuff and be able to see the
endgame and this is the thing like let's
say you put an orc on the fortress and
it gets taken over well then you have to
go back and try to retake it over so
there's that grind too so if you can't
defend it properly the first time you
have this grind cycle of going back and
trying to place another bull pop or
gonna try to defend it never see the
endgame so again the feeling is that
they develop the game in such a way and
that they push you towards buying these
crates with the home that you're gonna
have a mouth to be able to uh that's not
good okay that's just a shout out money
to tell you so yeah I can play me day
for the whole blue crate nonsense I
started madden ultimate team and to care
down to the VC and my team packs that's
going to be suffocating wow it's going
wild in single-player games and again
we'd like single-player I don't mind
because the thing is if he wants to use
an amiibo man in town you know what you
pay for that amiibo you pay to put that
amiibo is a toy is visually stunning
baby statue exactly of something that
you love you may not you know the best
part of me knows is somebody can go
inside the store let's say a parent goes
inside a store they don't know anything
about their knowing you know what game
system goes to those look cute I'm a
given from Tommy Tommy has it and he's
like wow this is cute
I had a meatballs nut they didn't do
anything for awhile mmm when I got my
switch I found out they was actually
magic the Mabel thing is listen this is
DS a toys and they're cute that you put
them around your office you can put them
around your house you could have Mario
in a corner here and there
and they actually are functional in a
game that you might play later on um
these blue crates they're disposable
they're burnable and you have nothing
afterwards like I don't have a beef foot
amiibo cuz amiibo you have that's what
you say when you say this dough is like
one time used boom we out that's it
that's that's the beef that if people
are having with the Forza so now when it
comes to Forza with forza forza has
always had a credit system where
depending on how you do during the
course of a race you get X amount of
credits and you can use those credits to
purchase more cars this is a loop
they've had in-game diecast we talked
this would be money you know saying prep
um what you call from mr. maggot of
himself
we had instance at now I understand the
Forza trying because the force of how it
used to work like we talked about is
that you basically if you turned off
driving assists and all that stuff you
would give you the ability to earn more
credits right right and then now with
the VIP like the VIPs would have like
this extra boost so help me right okay
Bulls right right and then they will be
able to get you know a little bit more
so they thought they were gonna get
referred in grandfathered in with four
or seven right and comes find out it
wasn't and it was over but a few
purchased and on the premise of thinking
that is going to carry over and and this
is misleading here because I understand
what a community will get upset with
this that you assumed and it's really on
you force women because it was not in
the fine print but you frame that you've
done this for years it should also carry
over they cried about it and they got it
back to the unlimited status all right
yeah her give a son unlimited you can
use it a million times if you want they
didn't understand it and think or they
was trying to be sheisty anytime these
companies try to be shy Seto like hotels
to it and it will they
wall they will back face and get you
what you want immediately now shout out
to turn ten for actually doing that is
they could they didn't have to do that
they didn't have to reverse course and
throw that back on but we do know that
shadow for and now I'm hearing
Assassin's Creed is down with the loop
Assassin's Creed and Star Wars
Battlefront saw was lends to that though
yeah but battlefront CD battlefront is
really egregious like anybody who's
played the data over the weekend because
really the battlefront thing is kind of
nuts and again I haven't played the beta
but [ __ ] what I've been able to read
and I and you sound out to IGN for
having an article that kind of blows
this out a little bit so apparently they
have the same thing loot crate system
that contains upgrade cards within those
crates as in addition to what you know
whatever you know weapons ability
upgrades and stuff like that and all of
this stuff has real ramifications on how
you do in multiplayer like you apply
this stuff and you're immediately more
powerful than someone else right so the
thing is these hero cars is burning
upgrade cards it's all dependent on the
amount of cars that you can um that you
can equip at any point in time is
dependent on the amount of cards that
you have meaning if you open more crates
and pay for more crates you'll have more
slots to use during the game so let's
say they say they've you know whatever
ten slots right you don't you can't
access ten slots worth of card bonuses
until you open X amount of crates until
you pay for X amount of crates so it is
straight up pay to win and they're not
really been hiding it oh man like and
and again the phones yeah cell phones
for this it is it is the humans missed
need to see the numbers constantly going
up then kind of that has these systems
in place and I
understand we've talked about this in
the past and shout out to Phil Spencer
for trying to find alternate ways in
which to monetize single-player content
where it doesn't feel ugly and I know we
talked about you know putting games on
game paths and stuff like that ways to
make it so you don't have to have these
systems in particularly single-player
games right mm-hmm
I understand that these games are
expensive to make and are only getting
more expensive to ride let's talk about
doing a let's play devil listen let me
yeah leave the business you know I say
it real because that that's a factor
here right and people ask me might as
much as we complain him shout out to be
money shout out to mr. Magadan from
super deforming all that was on Pete
they they're putting it in for a reason
like they know people is the same thing
with VC as much as I can't stand it
I felt victim I didn't he came I was in
there on a switch right I'm in which an
NBA 2k start off you go to 145 Park
Yuchun round shirt right I'm a level 60
I'm coming to me and dude's got the full
posits who's got the jerseys you know
I'm saying like they real wavy they got
in the sevens under the name I'm getting
killed in my first three games and then
they'll make it worse off a progression
is so small when you win a game when you
get credit I guess so so the game is
purposely assuring me for that it's
built into the mechanic is so bad that I
believe there was a review out there
that gave it a 3 out of 10 because he's
like this game is forcing me to buy
because I can't enjoy it and it's it's
sad but that's where we are they're like
it I felt because like now I can't be
getting killed like this so I'm I don't
want a look at a full-on cop the pennies
from characters you short set go saying
like make my man look alone you know
about my dad
I'm adverse to doing this for paying for
content that I think that should be
implemented see it's a whole perfect
storm that has that brought this about
for us okay
the Internet and the fact that people
figured out that the developers figured
out that they can ship a game to you
broken and they can patch it right so
okay so this said I think that that
works that way um also we can deliver
constant content to the games on a
weekly or to day-to-day basis right on
the end that that'll work we can charge
extra for premium stuff Oh that'll work
Oh what about if we give them something
that we can charge for that makes the
game a little bit easier Oh that'll work
and it's gonna get to the point well
once they did free-to-play and that was
the phone model you get the game for
free you get to a certain point in this
game this little puzzle game where you
need more time you had two more moves
and you could have finished this off so
you purchase extra time and these little
coins or whatever you need to purchase
and a little menu pops up hey you get 25
Nestle's for $1.99 and you say to
yourself that's a small margin if a
million of you people million purchase
this $1.99 item brother they are raking
in the dough all right hold on a new
challenger has appeared and I just
passed out when I had the alarm going
through my headset but my headset is not
on my head I work 12 hours last night so
I got home and I was probably sleep by
8:20 and I get out at 8 o'clock it's so
good it's so good we're jumping in on
the lootcrate stuff but oh you got any
any any uh feedback on
Abdulla feedback on what's going on with
these Luke rakes how do you feel about
it yeah right they still have that
craziness where okay
so for still has Luke raised but they
just reverse course as far as the VIP
right the VIP they still have it so what
let's say okay you type of car right you
want to purchase your certain type of
car like a hot car like whatever hot top
and a lot of ports or whatever so it's
in teeters now so if you haven't
purchased X amount of cars and a tier
let's say the tiers below what you want
you can't purchase from that higher tier
so your forces of burns is now cars that
you don't even want in order to get to
that tier if you want to the in-game
currency way so it's like once again so
they're like what way if you really want
it just go buy it
shut up to be money he put that out
there so basically like you can't get
your body off the rip not an endo or
less you can't and you gotta pay body
cause in the levels and all these before
the multi-level before it and then you
get so you wasting crystals and
necessarily stuff that you don't want
yep so hey we talked about that - um
Brett that's crazy
yeah well you have this I mean I kind of
figured everyone saw this I guess I was
only one saw this like this
like not even in the slightest probably
this time next uh in the next couple
years we're going to be uh we're gonna
be paying for sections of games you have
finished mission six so do you want to
use your daggers to kill space $2.99 and
we'll give you those daggers only use
half of that dagger we need $1.99 to
finish that diamond what about for the
people who say see you know these games
are expensive I don't know saying I
don't have a problem with this as long
as they stick it to cosmetic but my
issue is is where are we going to
eventually draw the line that's my issue
because sooner or later you know it's
it's that scene it's like you snip your
toe in to see how hot the water is this
is the thing that the line has been
crossed already because they're not
sticking to cosmetics like Battlefront
to not sticking the cosmetics that's
taking the cars from the cosmetics you
know when it's always what tell me about
the battlefront soft what what is EA
doing you can build up crates and that
give you pieces of weapons and if you
have all the pieces it will make the
weapon and you can use it or is it a
cart or and legit weapon sovereign age
it's a little bit of everything it's two
guards in addition to weapons in
addition to our much stuff and whatnot
like so it's it's again it's probably
the worse than that it's it's true play
to win because all of the stuff as soon
as you get it you can equip it and run
out there multiplayer and be more
powerful than someone else who has it
that money right and you you weren't
here to hear this part of Attic but so
the thing is with these card slots right
you have the amount of slots that you
have to to to implement at any given
point in time is determined by the
amount of cards that you have the way
you get an abundance of cards is to
continue opening and buying
loot crate's so there's a direct
correlation about how many of these
cards you can implement at any given
point in time and how many you've
actually purchased so if you buy $500
worth of crates you're gonna have an
advantage over somebody who's who's
bought who's bought none who's bought a
hundred who bought 200 if I say I've
seen a lie ever since I played happy
Wars battlefronts do is operating like
NBA 2k you could have a distinct
advantage over your competition based on
how much money you spent the bad part is
equation where it's like do you neither
stand for your morals and it's like I'm
not buying this game because of what
they are practicing or do you miss every
big title because of loot crate's now
why want to skip every game that's
coming out now pretty much because of
the the practices that they're you know
that they're implying play games
stupidness with the season pass and the
DLC right so you're good normal purchase
of a game used to be 60 bucks and you
think that's how it goes but no you want
a season pass when they started putting
season pass for a single-player games I
know the jig was up get a season pass
like what was that about like okay and
sometimes you get a season pass for
games and you automatically purchase it
like I purchased the injustice - and I
got the season when it comes down to it
man I've always said it's like
developers make good games well I don't
make average
make good games you'll get you'll make
that good money here's the that here's
the thing all these developers want GTA
money and they don't have a GTA five
gangs and that's the thing and that's
the thing but the way they making their
money all right
obviously GTA the base game is you know
gangbusters anyway you put that it's
gonna sell it so like you billion them I
had a billion dollars in like three days
beer exactly now GTA online where's the
money being printed though GTA online
and not not every game has that where
you have the entire GTA 5 map the entire
world but it's completely different but
jumped out the door like that no
following oh absolutely or into the
billions a little oh not the doors no he
was not playing GTA when the first came
out when it was I was talking about five
G stomps all the rest to the grass
that's nice I'm talking about the
Genesis see what you're looking at is
you're looking at a finished product you
make not looking at the genesis of
bringing that crowd up they noticed by
the numbers they said how can we keep
this going
you know these news everybody purchase
this game and it stopped at a number how
can we get those dole's those 50 million
to 100 million people still paying
online baby what's online instruction
they put in stuff that I couldn't
believe like they put in literally
shipping keys and selling cars and guns
gun running where was the parents at
this point that your kid became
perfected conversation a couple of days
ago about GTA 5 and we were discussing
about the heist and stuff was like I
don't know man I think I make more money
running drugs like
scenarios were that sin is good no all
right let's bring it bring it in though
cuz it's letting we understand why it's
being done we understand the business
aspect we understand it's a success
thing you know but do we think all right
do we honestly Pig we use that statement
we're gonna have the willpower to do
that that's what me and addict or
aligned it I'm gonna get the pedal stuff
it's like driving in your car the street
the motion to the window just roll your
window on the most effective thing you
can do is buy you know if you okay first
off if you don't buy the game and you
know you have a huge amount of people
you might just not see that franchise
ever again and the second thing it's
like your vinegar guy if you guys better
spent on social media bitching at these
companies for doing these practices than
just banned boycotting their games yeah
I know that yeah I think you're right
about that
I don't like the chatter they don't like
on social media when they get when you
see that the uprise on social media
that's the only bud so what's going on
right now in the Destiny community let
me tell you right now like they are
going at DJ's head like shut up that my
boy a lawyer or a poet I see from Forbes
we will get you on the show baby put the
Twitter so you liked it
uh-huh like we're gonna get him on show
but the thing is like he even said like
the 1% is so vocal and trust me they see
that like they they watch the reddit
forms like people complaining about
destiny in a nossa is
number the top four most hottest
categories already so I think the answer
like you said Lord Atticus is not
necessarily like okay I'm not like
that's not affecting about you saying
I'm not gonna buy it to yourself but if
you kind of [ __ ] and moan too like
these Community Managers and already
what's what's more effective not buying
your game and only you and maybe a
handful of people know are you being one
of the notifications to a community
manager getting on Twitter to like fight
again about a thousand retweets on top
of some of the biggest you know changes
that's been done in gaming the gaming
industry I mean look at the the 2013
Xbox rephrase do you think that would
have happened if people just didn't buy
the Xbox one maybe sooner or later but
it would have happened so fast
mmm fax FedEx this is a government it's
a good moral discussion love the input
from laws if not we're gonna move on I
also want to move on to the next topic
which is lured addicts I want to shout
out to a lord Victor Alstyne Palestine
in the chat he had a quick question he
won is the Lord's to answer and he just
said his question was that with the fame
cut pad has seen do you think it'll
induce copycats from big companies like
EA or Activision especially like that
hand-drawn art style what are the Lord
saying and I feel like this well there's
been games in the past it's been hand
your own I don't know if people know
this but Scott a lot of Skyrim was hand
drawn too but um it's just that certain
artwork I don't know like there are
games like pub G and stuff that other
developers would just straight-up yank
obviously we've seen that before at
night but there is a perspective to
where it's like companies don't want it
straight out get told that their coffee
in you know what I'm say it in coffee
cup head specifically there's not really
much you know angles they can take to
not just being say yeah coffee yeah it's
gonna be obvious it's good you know they
tough it is a labor of love man like
that is a one and only game play copy
that yeah you will be called out
with oh it's a butyl laughing now what
what about just like the hand-drawn art
style in Jena because I think Laura
Victor also made a comment like he would
love to see like a fighting game or
something like that to that effect with
something it's just there's a lot more
games hand-drawn people just don't know
it's just getting the finished product I
mean if if you wouldn't have her to saw
any kind of dev you know updates some
people might even think up it might not
even know cup it Sandra yes that's true
Lord Louis on will you out with that
yeah I mean I think the hand grow
especially for fighting games that would
love that
I mean when you look at channel
technology guilty gear that draw a game
from playing I think that's and wrong
draw the death you know
Dragon Ball fighters II when you look at
the persona fighting game those games
are beautiful I got more finding games
in that fame because that's kind of the
middle ground I like what we can't it's
very hard to get picks in our games
you're not you're not gonna get too many
people you know pixel artists being able
to create a full-fledged game it's just
too difficult to find people with that
expertise nowadays so you know having
something hand dry like that that's to
be that's where you should go
I don't even think it's really you know
just the art style that make up pick up
head I think it's the humor that's
behind
cuphead the the difficulty of the nozzle
the humor of the balls of the humor
cuphead is a perfect marriage of all
these great things right you know I got
into a port where I'm fighting literally
I finally beat the robot let me make a
public announcement I beat the road on
stream shout-out to my stream you can go
look at that I let her lose
hyperventilating because I was breathing
so it hard because like I felt like I
was having a heart attack
well I mean Mero do you guys cuphead
legit we almost killed me yes with is
real that I just I really do because
it's like and Nina was also a cop it
doesn't it is the perfect streaming game
because it's so difficult and you want
to see
if people struggled at a party you
struggled out how they did something it
really has that little subculture
attitude that I like as well I know how
you guys feel about that well it's a
beast within itself I've always said
from the moment that you saw it you knew
it was different and you hope before you
got it getting your hands on it that it
would bring everything together
the music is spot-on the colors even the
filters the black and white filter that
you put in it it's spot-on and it
harkens back to back in the days if you
are old enough that you remember Mickey
Mouse in black and white yes and you
know for the younger generation you can
get a chance to peek into the window of
the older crowd in this game Lord I
could come in for your you for your neck
Lord addict I did that live on stream
and look I pop you go meet you at the
finish line is like because like those
cartoons that those old-school car tools
that we grew up on and Tom and Jerry's
and stuff like that hey when you watch
the characters just make you smile and
laugh so hard inside at myself because
I'm playing that is so spot-on the boss
is like just to see the face in the
reactions it just it makes me laugh it
is just so so beautifully done but
they'll [ __ ] up everybody give shout out
the long-legged shot at the Chapman you
know carpet beautiful it really is and
it doesn't I'm just glad to see a game
like this win right you know say like
this is exclusive to like this once a
generation win yeah and they needed it I
did ask how you know you know you know
the inner circle podcast last night
to them but uh I asked them do you guys
think that Microsoft should buy this
title make it a mascot I mean it's too
late
things to like but they only I mean they
pretty much it can't come out on another
platform from my understanding my thing
is don't franchise it don't don't muddle
the waters with it it's kind of like
Incredibles we've been dying for an
Incredibles tool for years like come on
push it up but the movie was so good
from beginning to end that you never
called for it right so now there's
Microsoft and you know how Microsoft do
they get a franchise and they gonna run
it to the floor um and that's not what
you want to see done with this game okay
could you put like a cuphead RPG or
cuphead fighters with that company great
you know what humor of these people I'm
surprised they didn't legitly have a
loot crate box in this game no thanks we
got that okay I shout the victor for
that question that was a good one for
the chat we gonna move on actually blow
addicts back in a building so I talked
about the skill level of certain people
in the industry you want to talk about
that yeah I mean we really uh call any
people out that's not the intention of
the iron Lords took me personally well
I've always considered Metacritic a joke
because all it takes someone could
literally go in there hate the fable
franchise give that give that a two out
of ten just cuz they don't like the
fable franchise Metacritic is gonna
honor that is gonna bring the entire
Metacritic score down so you know I've
never really understood why people use
Metacritic you know to valley I guess I
think that's more of like a console war
thing there's a lot of websites that
benefit from the console war let me tell
you guys something
you know foundry benefits from the
console war Medicaid benefits from the
console war but that that's a completely
different route of the rant so you know
I wanted to go into what do you guys do
you guys think there is a qualification
- you know reviewers being able to
complete the game that they beat or the
you know first off you know that there
are you know bad stuff going around
right now with people cheating on
cuphead do you guys think that stuff
like that matters because I personally
don't like the way I see it is like look
I do think it's a little jacked up that
there are some people that you know
there was the the journalist that guy
that did the gameplay I can't remember
his name and you know some people have a
hard time getting reviewing games like
this because you know they don't have
that that install base of people that
follow them or that are you know they
had that flushing of that huge major a
website they can get review copies and
they can't get past tutorial levels yeah
each other cut head dude the vid out of
that one what do you guys think do you
think that it should be something that
is mandated to be good and had the game
that you at least go for a lot King
Simon I don't like the fact that you
have bums playing games don't tell me
about a fighting game and you can't tell
me what cancels out a mid punch to
allocate no don't don't don't review the
game if your skills doesn't um how can I
say yes your skills doesn't qualify you
to say a word about the game like I
won't I would say loyal carboxyl is the
one I can review cuphead you know what
boss what boss well I'm playing on
regular sir I'm playing on simple and
then I go back and I play it on regular
after I get down to simple mechanics and
I died a million times I am not
qualified for that so why would you pay
somebody who isn't qualified to do that
don't pay them take that money away
to gamers who are actually qualified my
name the reason you see this so frequent
and you know people want that hip-hop
game or last Louie for his Fiasco you
know he's a fan of the UH he's a fan and
a friend of the podcast like well I
think you know hip hop is an exception
like you know obviously I don't condone
what he done I don't understand why he
would shame something like that all we
talk when talking to cheat code stuff
yeah but like for the games Thank You
peace there's a lot of journalists that
literally will play a half the game and
do a review like with hip hop right I do
feel like there was a point to that you
know obviously I don't I don't know if
hip hop could ever do cuphead but you
know from someone that I went there to
see hip hop felt like when I went to
kids yeah I'm glad you said that because
part of my love of what you because you
don't want to see the baby cuz hip hop
said that he wanted his viewer to see
the game in its integrity the whole game
so I could kind of understand that to a
point because you know he got a cave but
I can understand you did it like you
know what I'm saying
but like if you would think about it's
like you know if you want your viewer
base to actually see that you know that
game you would have to use something
like that because you I do in the [ __ ]
he done and they store them at a time he
did it there's no crutch for that
there's no your gamer so um alright no
magic Genie that was frowned upon in our
circles you had to hide that in your
book back bro the fact that you went on
air you shoot you add that out like that
pro pro that's your game is real
looking right at you with the red-eye
bro and you're giving you skills has
been called under fire bro that moves up
bro I don't know there are certain
people out there that claims like
they're the you know their gift to games
like they're so good at them and like
them people in particular they did some
nonsense like this that's when I'll be
like yeah that that's a little suspect
see I feel what you say only issue what
reason what now in hip hop's defense I'm
not listen you know I agree what you
saying looking I'm not trying to sit Dan
cosine but at the same time like was he
putting out an official review of the
game like we're gonna get all
impressions I think I do think he had oh
you guys continue I'll look at that
stream and see because my feeling this
is where I across a lot for me not his
actions I'm just saying like it
reviewers actions because my thing is as
a reviewer like if you're gonna make a
publication of written thing you're
talking to community doubt whether or
not you should you know I'm saying get
this game I think this in this sport so
you're tolerating okay the first one
said cup had live review on PC that's
when he was getting owned because I did
so they review no no no listen he did
start the first stream had no cheat
codes in then he came back a day later
and he did a cup head is a is a hit
oh my god PC 4k gameplay time that's the
ones who use cheats on okay listen my
give me it was an exhibition you can do
whatever you got
no receipt you put up your game genie
you put up your code and say I just
follow my spy myself as a true gamer you
are not he he even came out join us too
hard like my thing is when you he didn't
cheat on you work hard you train you got
yourself in this you did you beat the
robot and we're not tired to say he was
reviewing the game and he didn't even
lie about it the dude was reviewing the
game and he was straight up line that he
was so when they come out they said it
is ok like yo you know we'll be into
like what does it matter this dues a bad
game how is this game all the way
through the game did you catch me but I
did I did I put a cheat code into
anything and all my game is I get my
game on if I win and I win the fight
another day
my question is for the reviewers right
but they do the Kotaku who's the
polygons do the IGN oh my god anchorman
did she that she King is too started we
going on the detour to the right and not
straight I seen some reviews on on
YouTube I'm not gonna go on which
websites but uh they said they were
reviewing the game and I could clearly
tell they played the whole game on
simple and one even had the audacity to
say this game wasn't on hard and I've
seen him playing one of the bosses in
the background on simple is that okay
it's in the game it's in the game did he
put up the did he cheat but he never
came out and said he played on alright
there's a mole played a game right
it's a mole easier alright alright so
you push you push left are you upset
that he went simple you went hard and
your game of skill is higher than his
and he wants to know it's not about that
like it's about him saying this game's
not okay all right so you go eat it and
beat it or hearts away he said the game
was too easy and we play it was too easy
he said this game isn't as hard as
people make it out to be and that but
he's playing a boss in the background on
simple
I'll go into this after like and you
know I don't know for you guys knows but
if you play it on simple certain ball
certain phases of the ball stone is not
going on simple I get the gist down
right now when you go in on normal it it
switches up for you but you already got
the simple mechanics down oh oh you need
to play it on you need to play the game
on whatever the base mode is where you
can get the entire experience and if
you're like me to [ __ ] in that mode you
whatever that base experiences you
should not be reviewing yeah I feel like
any game that you you review to that
mode it should always be played like at
least on the the default settings of
viewing the game okay now what about
let's switch it now what about for the
people who are putting up reviews that
maybe have not finished again that's not
right because the thing is the point of
the review is to give an overall feeling
on the entire game and that includes
endgame stuff like if you're giving me
your review opinion my assumption by
heroine review is that you finished the
game and you have a full opinion to give
me if you haven't finished it who's to
say that the end game doesn't suck like
who's to say a lot of the big reviewers
already do this know is you stop the
trend you show your game from beginning
to end and everybody right you 100% I
told you I jump into your joint I don't
look at it I click a like on it because
I know you're doing it I know you're
actually putting that blood sweat kill
me company could you imagine if you died
and this guy actually did a performance
enhancers and didn't die
because this is definitely a homicide it
depends a lot of people if you go online
to see you know certain like youtubers
and whatnot review of a game unless
you've been in bet you've been invested
in this person's work up until now like
you want to hear what they kind of have
to say about the game but I'm not
necessarily coming to these guys for
full-on straight-up reviews I'm gonna
lie I'm gonna buy the game based on what
they said don't say I'm going to the
Kotaku's I'm going to the polygon I'm
going to the waypoints I'm going to the
night ends my Game Informer's my giant
bombs this is one more you're going to
as president as Professor posted a
little dude oh yeah absolutely because
for the most part these guys in the game
these guys are YouTube like wife that
does destiny you know Ryan McCaffrey
because uh besides that like I think
that's the only like so most the time I
look at a review and like I don't
respect the reviewers so much I just see
what he reviewed it like what score you
cover fraud this is a fraud like they
have previewed they got people writing
previews of games a month out right
right and these are people who are just
in playing the game they're gonna give
you a gist of what the game is you may
not necessarily be the person that
reviews the game in the end maybe
someone else perspectives you get at the
end of the day it's on Union who take
that perspective in yes right see
here's the thing no like I understand
what you saying los sob but I think I'm
a little bit of the opposite only for
the standpoint like from when we came up
we had the ideas the egm the game pros
getting spots and all that and then you
know like when I felt like some of them
dudes was in bed with the companies yeah
and was in saying the real real so now
anybody have like a YouTube era now
where you got the cactuses where I'm say
the wrong thing you blacklisted for like
you know kakasii just came on the show
like you'll notice do put out good
content we gonna call it what is he
gonna put Bungie to the carpet and be
like yo this is what it is so sometimes
I feel like but that's not everybody
that's thinking they are generally guys
okay then you have you guys were like
quantico influencers who are getting the
game fraud from these um development
companies and then you know it's almost
assumed that you you're not necessarily
gonna run it into the ground because
they are you right right you right much
as people like certain dudes out with
this there's some channels that their
whole shtick is to hate or something
right yeah like I'm not with you ya know
when I'm going and I got no problems
with nobody but I'm just saying like in
general there's certain channels that
that's their thing you know I mean if
certain companies will be like man I'm
not putting my drain over there with you
did they feel away you know them saying
so I see what you say you are right low
sob I take it back you are it is
definitely that influence is also now
seeping in to the bigger
YouTube influencers and they're trying
to gauge and try to cultivate try to
have access to many different viewpoints
just like Moby money's just looking at
them he's going on just to get
impressions he has a huge idea of what
he's interested in that he's just he's
just using the different sources from I
feel like that that's the case for
majority the arc or like only as you get
correct with this [ __ ] guys show you the
syringe no I'm not saying that you can
donate and actually I'm defending you
I'm defending your hard work your blood
your sweat your tests so don't ever
think that I'm saying you're condoning
that because if you were condoning that
you would have got his Chico but you'll
get solid on 5bs where they went to
review bouquet it's got 40 hours use
cheats didn't play chapter 2 but they do
remember that I was right
yo but Anka's wrath there's so much that
entire reviewing scenario is corrupted
like everything is like you know people
got yeah we we see people literally you
know lying about them playing a full
game I mean we're talking about like
people who get paid to do this for a
living
and when it comes down to it's like look
like you know dude what did hip-hop do
what was right no it wasn't but we got
way worse things in this industry than
hip-hop gamer cheating on my friend
exactly so he was doing it and it's not
okay savage right now but that's all I
got are we gonna definitely get shot
unless you tell me um yeah we definitely
get hip hop back on the show we want him
to the finish cevlar king has has called
him out on the coffee yes go be a paper
that yeah take the gloves off this time
I'm not gonna let a walk history so cool
we're gonna have to have we get hip-hop
Lord hip-hop back on we're gonna have
topic in called Lord K versus learned we
ain't going to let them go at it looking
rightfully so you are in comic-con
Street hey guys this week the king went
to comic-con and I got a watch from a
caller like you know I'm a friend of
mine he came under dire straits he
couldn't get the time off from work and
he purchased some tickets so um you know
and he needed help I didn't have no
plans I'm going to Comic Con so I said
you know I purchased the tickets from
you and you know as a big strenuous
thing because it's tied to your email
and your ID and all this other stuff and
you know he finally got him switched
over to my name or whatever and you know
I took my kids to Comicon so I've never
been a Comic Con and it was one of my
things on my bucket list like III was
now the first time I went to e3 it was
magical it was like Disney World for a
child to be honest with you and it was
the greatest experience ever a shout-out
to Microsoft for have a fan fest that
took it to the next level like my e3
experience to the next level and then
again shout out this year for Microsoft
for saving my III experience because
this year they opened it up to the
public and I'm adverse to that because
of what I'm going to talk about next
oh I got the Comic Con bright eye
pushing till ready to go and I'm saying
everybody walking in with a cosplay
suits and they're looking nice and not
so many people cosplays but you know you
can come and you can feel at home and
there's no judgment you know you if
you're fat in your Deadpool you just a
fat Deadpool if you are venom you're
just a skinny venom you know and it's
wonderful to see people comfortable and
being accepted at that point now the
show
when you walk in the door I want to tell
you everybody have you're a mess up your
ones your M's make sure your bank
account is up to par go check your bank
account make sure that you have enough
money to spend all right I would suggest
before you go to Lourdes at Comic Con
probably spend what it cost for my I'm
going to tell you why no um you must say
from last year's comic-con to this
year's Tommy Tong I would say at $100 a
week to be able to enjoy yourself okay
when you walk in the door it's like a
swap meet
it is literally a swap meet with every
comic book cuddler in the world they're
selling his old comic books for this
price of that price t-shirts by
abundance and hike the prices
everything has got that extra price tag
price on top of it there's nothing free
to be given there like when you go to
eat three you get a free bag you know I
walked in at it they gave you bags and
you just take it you like oh man thanks
I can put some free stuff inside here
that I'm gonna get because I know when I
leave this place I'm gonna have so much
free stuff cuz I pay to get in here
I didn't pay to play this is what this
is comic-con
is pay to play everyone is selling you
something like what are you gonna get me
bro
uh-uh no no but we got a new book here
that just came out by this author that
is really good buy well how much is it
bro oh that's $25 bro what's going on
with you guys so I'm looking at these
guys we went around the whole place you
know and my kids is walking around mind
you looking at this place like it's cool
but they like let's get a shirt yes
nothing
do there but walk around and go to
people stands and let them peddle you
somewheres tell you some wares and you
may walk pass
I am in that some guy and I am a suit
that did the nice little Iron Man suit
you take a picture with him if it's not
for these cosplay dudes and these
cosplay dudes need to get paid they
should pray them are amazing the people
that's coming up with it and when they
walk in the door if you're in a costume
you should come in free and as you give
you fifty bucks
that's what they should do because y'all
see the stuff on TV so if you never been
in you say oh my god it looks so amazing
it's not it's not every time you turn
around somebody is digging in your
pocket for something awesome yes it's
such a shame that it broke my heart
it broke my heart honestly because I see
the future of III oh don't say don't
scare me up don't say okay yes because
last year did we see that giant wall of
t-shirts
did anybody design wall t-shirts I
remember Laura Laura Cognito you you
head up what's his name about about
picked them up so that the material was
nice did you see it last year no no no
no okay when when was free to the pub
when the public was able to come aside
they had to purchase tickets that's when
they said we're gonna peddle these
things to them our free stuff drops and
the purchase stuff went up I had to
purchase swag this year III my thing to
you guys is is it appealing to you that
they hi comic-con under the guise and
they're saying that panel guys are gonna
be there like Robert Downey jr. will be
here this day to talk okay
his thing in Iron Man and these guys are
not there long some panels run long
and there's no subsonic space there for
you to sit down so you have to stay the
whole time shop to talk about he's right
I've been one and it yeah those panels
when those celebs are there that that
line is around the corner around you
know it's long and yeah you're right
saying that the panel did a show with
Black Panther spider-man it's called
marvel life Marvel Live has a show that
will be on it's like a Broadway show
where they have stuntmen and everybody
fighting so they were showing again they
were peddling wares to you because they
said listen you can go right now to
purchase tickets and such a such a such
a such and get yourself in not here's a
ticket for half off everybody who attend
today not here's a free ticket for no
mmm let me let me ask you this before
you get it to the wrestler like do you
feel like what are you what do you want
them to do like what do you think needs
that you obviously with the peddling
where's we know like you're not affair
to that I'm trying to sell you some Mary
five minutes I get that like but like
what are you what do you think is the
Center for them to do besides the
hitting off the UM cosplay people like
to make it more appealing to you or
people going to go in a compound versus
III I'm never going back because I don't
ever see a way of redemption from them
because is that such a fever pitch that
these individuals they're able to they
feel a part of something right and it's
the cosplay people they chef cosplay con
actually should and you will take that
away from comic-con and it won't be
anything there and we sell comic books
and we sell books and we saw t-shirts
and light-up hats
there was actually a painting fear of DC
Universe whatever the painting if you
notice I posted it on Facebook and
Twitter 25 grand
little Johnny that's not for little
Johnny yo they had a $20 limit I had it
I impose the $20 limit they didn't buy
$20 for anything they didn't see
anything that they said that was worth
that 20 bucks I spent $20 on some
Submariner comic books that were there
and it's at a point where I felt that
same little feeling that I felt that III
this year hmm
we take the time out we come to your
venue you don't give us anything but you
want us to promote your venue and
there's nothing but buy this and you
will you attended it dave is an elitist
super leader status that I've never seen
any place before nothing I have I get
business cards that's what I got for
free business cards Wow all right Lord
stuff was coming like last c3 was my
first e3 but it being the first one with
with the public in there you knew they
were gonna try to find ways to to market
merchant stuff like that you knew that
you were to see bore that I'm gonna see
more you know food vendors whatever the
case may be it's just it's just if you
want to keep III as big as it is and
have and not have the companies
complaining about the amount of money
they have to spend to to promote their
it to be there
this is the Serta stuff that's gotta
happen night and you look at comic-con
and when you look at something like
packs these have always been more more
fan friendly sort of events is more
geared towards the fans so when you walk
through that door you're gonna see what
you're gonna see is people small you
know small people small companies
whatever peddling their wares that's
what it is because it's for quote
unquote fans all the big stuff that
you're gonna see there yeah particularly
I got a comic-con it's like you said
it's panels and stuff like that beyond
that just walking around the showroom
floor all you go to
people trying to sell you stuff you're
not gonna see like at e3 and e3 the
whole purpose of the show floor is for
you to go to each individual you know
developer or publisher you go to their
kiosk or whatever and you'll be able to
at least see their games if not play
their games so it's different like you
go to each thing and you're the
expectation is do gonna see something
new that you haven't seen before
or that you've been wanting to see
whereas comic-con everything that you
really want to see it's gonna be really
packed it's gonna be really isolated
from everything else and it's it and
you're gonna have to suffer to be able
to see it beyond that all you're gonna
get is people trying to sell you stuff
because yes but we're people like you
know smaller companies and things like
that go to be able to peddle their wares
because this war on France stuff the
same thing happens at PAX so I mean it's
you better see more of it at e3
depending on what they do with III this
year if they decide to go back to close
they would say I don't think they will
yeah we're just gonna see more that yeah
I jump in real quick I mean I definitely
feel a lot king saying about like I want
to I went to was it wizard Con in New
York but I went to wizard coms like
Philly or whatever was ain't dumb
outside of the fact that like they had
like a tekken 7 2014 7 was actually
released i wanted to get a feel of the
game so I did the job down there
whatever they will check it out and then
like he's saying it's like I was very
underwhelmed it was just hurt like a
whole bunch of like you certainly like I
swat me like it's a whole bunch of
people selling you stuff there's a
little set up areas to buy stuff um you
know as far as fanservice and stuff the
stuff that you would care about like
okay like the actors or you know this
person from this movie you know anything
to do with Marvel them lines with crazy
the lines are crazy like around them you
know really long people standing that
kind of stuff you know they had the fool
core but it's like you know unless
you're really a connoisseur of trying to
buy like maybe an older like you say
like look things that like all the comic
welcome stuff like that or you know
certain things but even to see people
you know may not be like a list you
don't say like shot look at your head
take that
DiBiase was in the building take a
picture you can't do this like it does
seem Comic Con feels overly monetized
right like that was the vibe now in
their defense the real one I hear is San
Diego comic-con I hear that's the one
okay so I want to give it one last shot
you know whiff you know get the ability
to go there I definitely want to do that
definitely want to see it in its glory
because that's where like all the big
announcement Avengers you get the
timeline you get all the secrets drop
you know I'm saying like trail is like
that's what I want to see and that's
what I want to give that now as far as
III you know I've seen a little bit of
the creep in you know say obviously with
them making it public last year whatever
you know there's definitely a change but
I can attest you know the difference
between 2017 III in 2016 there was a
difference you know saying and I think
with them is they need to figure out a
way to give the people who are actually
in the industry some type of early
access or a day to themselves to you
know either separate that cuz it was
kind of madness you know I'm saying so I
mean that's what that's what I got on it
you know I know what a dick you sitting
this one for that that's pretty much
where I with it I still eat he's
definitely better to comic-con I just
hope that he 3 doesn't go that route of
overly monetizing everything like that
what's up
totally frightful yeah that's what I got
so long we got it looks like we got a we
got a two polls kick it out before we
have your side but you guys actually
came up with a go so yo one let's start
with Johnny you guys want to talk about
the blue Krait situation as far as like
people are they still gonna buy it
regardless is that we rollin rollin yeah
okay so we got we got though 12 not do
it because I had one too and it was
basically it was it was in reference to
the Civil War as well
and um being being able mr. last week so
we've got we'll definitely the Beaufort
and the fact that question will be you
know do we feel bungee and over
casualized the game and the day-to-day
activities of destiny to at the expense
of the hawk called fan base a yes well
just turn her back on the hard code base
with no real grind and game to keep
playing
OB no testing to is better more
accessible fun for the masses now the
destiny one ever was so we will have two
poles up we like that loot crate in the
building as well
please Rock the Vote hit them Twitter
polls when it goes up I'm saying so Lord
at it with Lord Lord King effects
because the Lord of sleep do we got to
be more cuphead streams go no not today
I'm going back to bed I was like forty
some minutes late for the podcast I was
like I should just go back to bed like I
made myself you know but uh let me I
probably I might do when I wake up
doesn't go back to bed I think I'll eat
something or go back to bed I'm on the
I'm on the dice dude he's I've already
liked how the dice t works is you day he
does kind of like a roulette table if
you will leave and you got mini-bosses
for every flop oh you can be fighting
five or six people before you slice
advice dude Wow it's whatever for the
most part all all of those little mini
bosses are there they're not that hard
they're bunch of punks but look at that
man all with no performance enhancers
half-sleep who beat cuphead using a DDR
pad that's for doing what he did it with
a DDR pad it did not put in the cheek oh
no not at all
shout out to that guy
yeah one hand behind this back day but
definitely follow me on twitter my
gamertag off on PSN and xbox is a room
to kill thanks for all coming definitely
like that like the podcast he don't mind
and uh I'm out no doubt Lord
sovereign we can find people find you
can actually find me online might be no
net read right now I wish I could but
you know wife he's folding that but
that's the deaths that but they could
find me on PSN and xbox live at px
sovereign and what's up IOP on Twitter
you definitely are running out of time
before reset now those know that look
dig we can find people find you
Instagram Twitter Facebook PlayStation
they said oh man almost forgot
sad day and PlayStation nation I'm
selling one of my pros and a VR crap oh
you're selling VR let's dance telling
the PlayStation VR crap because I just
saw them you know they dare to cut me
bro they came out with a whole new let
me tell you something one of the biggest
deterrents with the PlayStation or VR
right now is when you're loading it up
and if you have to do a HDR bypass you
have to load up and safe mode um and it
distracts heavily from you know you
wanting to play to the game and you know
getting into it you know you gotta
constantly reboot your system that's why
it's our link to my 1080p television
listen they're done I'm gonna just stay
with pcs VR they have shown me that
they're willing to just they didn't give
you a program he'll ship your old crap
back in and uh you know we take off a
hundred dollars or you know whatever 115
and give you the you know the new joint
keep you here cuz you you helped us go
for it no Sony did what Sony does and
you know what look I'm you know told me
what's happening is now I'm selling a
pro system with our next row
yeah I'm selling a pro you a new headset
that still is the same power just some I
know their VR that's a bad look you
can't do that you can't yeah of course
it is spread that game Rin is on ILP you
know saying so yo first of all shout out
to the chat that it was extremely loud
you'll shout out first I want to shout
out Fame you gave us a big shout out
just now favoring the cadence our
brothers from 2xp podcast just gave us a
big shout out right now we really
appreciate the love and support please
hit that like and subscribe so everyone
that's on these um ILP and the inner
circle median network outlets also to
YouTube's the iTunes the Google Play so
that's gonna be up and of course that
amazing tech GN patreon we got that pop
and please support we are here giving
you a good content you know reading a
lot of fun and we really appreciate it
so on make sure you do that and yeah I
said the poles are gonna be up we're
gonna have those rockin we got some
stuff cooking I can't get into it
there's some special stuff cooking and
next couple of weeks hopefully you guys
are being really excited for and we
really appreciate you guys rocking with
us and on that note we about the end
this thing these